bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouvel
épisode pas des revues du monde puisque
je teste en ce moment un nouveau format
qui va être plutôt un format de deux
débats une cage j'ai pas encore trouvé
de nom d'ailleurs pour ce format mais
l'idée c'est qu'on va débloquer des
choses toutes catégories confondues et
ça peut aussi bien être des films comme
on va faire aujourd'hui que des séries
que des choses des éléments un petit peu
plus pop culture ou alors carrément des
théories complotistes
et aujourd'hui j'ai le plaisir de
recevoir une invitée merveilleuse je
suis trop contente de la souris sur la
chaîne donc c'est clotilde de la chaîne
youtube passé sauvage
salut à tous est ce que tu peux te
présenter ainsi peut pas vraiment donc
moi j'ai la chaîne passé sauvage qui est
une chaîne qui est plus garry's
l'archéologie l'anthropologie les
sciences du manège sociale ou pas mal
et donc si j'ai invité clotilde
aujourd'hui c'est parce que nous allons
faire quelque chose un petit peu
spéciale à savoir clotilde à cette
particule d'être archéologue de
formation mais de n'avoir jamais vu
j'avais vu les indians début j'ai eu le
un hockey et j'ai vu le quatrième grosse
prouesse hockey parce que le 4
je sais qu'il ya une connerie à un
moment que ça ça pourrait m'intéresser
alors pourquoi le 2 parce que je voulais
que tu qu'on regarde un épisode d'
indiana jones que tu n'as jamais vu
donc là l'objectif de cet épisode de
cette émission c'est que on va regarder
indiana jones et on va où tu es bunker
entre guillemets l'archéologie dans
indiana jones et ben écoute c'est parti
la partie allait il
[Musique]
ah oui c'est avec sa femme sa fille ava
qui bat à la blonde c'est la femme de
spielberg
bref hcb pas bayard il la rencontre sur
ce film d'accord la dessus je vous
suggère de me donner ce que vous me
devez nous allons nous fâcher ya mende
je veux
rose a mûri en votre sein indiana jones
à la base c'est quand même censé être un
prof d'archéologie on est d'accord un
prof de fac
moi je trouve ça très surprenant que
dans tous les films il soit présenté
justement comme le mec qui va récupérer
enfin qui va clairement fouiller des oui
c'est un saint dizier m'enfin c'est un
espion en fait ton avis d'archéologues
sur la question est-ce que indiana jones
c'est un archéologue au sens propre du
terme bah pas du tout bas non non mais
vraiment pas du tout mais en même temps
c'est de la fiction
ouais et ça prouve au contraire que
l'archéologie c'est vraiment pas vendeur
moi même scène ce salon on aurait plein
de sous pour faire des fouilles ce
serait super chouette c'est pas étonnant
que les américains et cette vision là de
l'archéologie parce que ils n'ont pas de
moyen âge ces gens là ils ont un passé
qui est très très court par rapport à
l'europe par exemple et donc ça joue
énormément sur les symboles et les
représentations moi je trouve que c'est
vraiment le james bond quoi c'est pas du
tout à ce chercheur oui parce que c'est
un archéologue sam usher charge
quelqu'un qui est à la fa qui a dit bio
tech ou sur le terrain habillés en
treillis remettre témoin nur hatch le
fouet
[Musique]
c'est ça nous rassure il est pas très
grand à l'intérieur se trouvent les
cendres de norak ok c'est plutôt malin
parce que murat si du coup c'est
réellement un oprah qui a vraiment
existé
c'était le premier empereur de la
dynastie ching et ça fait sens qu'ils
soient à la recherche de césure en
particulier en tout cas de ses cendres
et ce très important parce que d'un
point de vue symbolique la dynastie
ching c'est la dernière dynastie
impériale de chine
donc c'est quelque chose qui est très
importante pour le pour le peuple
chinois
alors pour remettre dans le contexte à
l'époque la chine elle est gouverné par
la dynastie ming
les scribes usure chaîne qui occupe le
nord-est de l'asie
ils sont leurs vassaux sont soumis après
la mort de son père en 1582 nu rachid
décide d'unifier toutes les tribus jour
chaîne et ça va lui prendre un sacré
paquet d'années parce que toutes les
tribus elles sont gouvernées
indépendamment il comprend très vite
qu'il va falloir changer les choses s'il
veut s'attaquer à l' empire chinois et
pour ça il va progressivement transformé
des tribus indépendante donc qui se
[ __ ] sur la tronche en une
bureaucratie militaire très efficace
c'est seulement en 1616 qu'il dévoile
ses véritables ambitions et qu'il se
déclare lui même
cannes c'est à dire celui qui commande
et il rejette officiellement le statut
de sujet de l' empire chinois les années
suivantes il continue l'expansion de son
territoire mais cette fois ci en
s'attaquant directement au ming vont pas
de bol parce qu'ils crèvent en 1626
avant d'avoir pu réaliser son ambition
ce sont ses fils qui vont finir la
conquête de l'empiré chinois et
officialiser la dynastie qing en 1644
murat ci est donc considéré comme le
premier empereur de la dynastie qing à
titre posthume puisqu'il est
l'instigateur de la dynastie
s'affaissant soit qu'ils aient qu'ils
aient pris son corps sous forme de
cendres parce qu'on sait qu'au xviie
siècle la crémation c'était une pratique
qui était relativement commune chez les
jours chaîne et donc c'est tout à fait
plausible qu'ils aient bu incinéré le
corps de nos racines et d'ailleurs c'est
plutôt bien joué en fait de la part des
scénaristes de l'avoir mis sous cette
forme là parce que un c'est plutôt plus
plausible d'un point de vue historique
et 2 ça permet comme ça à indiana jones
de se trimballer avec une petite tournée
avec un cadavre
c'est plus sympa mais est-ce que indie
il aurait pu mettre la main sur l'urne
denurra ci est ce que est ce que c'est
crédible en fait george lucas et steven
spielberg
ils ont probablement entendu parler d'un
fait divers qui a fait beaucoup beaucoup
de bruit en 1928 le pillage des tombes
de la dynastie ching après l'abdication
du dernier empereur ching en 1912 la
république de chine est instaurée mais
c'est très rapidement le sbbl avec des
seigneurs de guerre partout dans le pays
qui se disputent l'autorité
c'est dans ce contexte qu'a lieu le
pillage des tombes de la dynastie qing
en 1928 un des seigneurs de guerre lance
une grande opération de pillage du
mausolée orientale les soldats devenus
pilleurs ils s'en donnent à coeur joie
il n'hésite pas à bousculer les cadavres
des empereurs et de leurs familles pas
cool pour récupérer les objets situés
autour des corps il aurait été jusqu'à
déshabiller le cadavre de l'impératrice
cixi pour voler sa robe ses sous
vêtements et ses chaussures pas cool
donc indie qui retrouve les restes de
l'empereur fondateur de la dynastie qing
dans les années 30 est bon c'est pas du
tout une mauvaise idée en soi sauf qu'à
priori le mausolée fooling dans lequel
se trouve n'eurent assis lui il n'a pas
été pillée puisqu'il se trouve pas dans
la même ville j'espérais que vous
excellence ça fait cheap quand même les
décors insolites qui s'écartent une tête
décapitée de m'éclairer sur quelques
points de victoire encore mal connue du
palais dont l'importance de son rôle et
dans la grande meeting c'est trop drôle
qui parle de la mutinerie de 1857 parce
que c'est une révolte qui a réellement
existé mais les entend il l'appelle
plutôt la première guerre d'indépendance
ou la révolte des cipayes depuis le 17e
siècle la compagnie britannique des
indes orientales a le monopole sur le
territoire indien
sa devise diviser pour mieux régner
alternant entre corruption et violences
la compagnie montrent les monarques
locaux les uns contre les autres et
choisi d'aider ceux qui lui sont le plus
utiles du coup début du 19e siècle
elle a eu le temps de bien
planté partout en inde et a
progressivement grignoté tout le pouvoir
possible
les cadres de la compagnie se sont
considérablement enrichis met sur le dos
des populations locales qui elles sont
de plus en plus pauvre des familles
frappe le pays à répétition mais
dépourvu de gouvernement propre
l'inde ne peut défendre ses intérêts les
conditions des indiens se dégrade
d'année en année sans parler de celle
des soldats indiens engagé dans l'armée
de la compagnie les six paille est
l'élément déclencheur de la révolte
eh bien ce sont de simples munitions
d'après le réglement britannique
les soldats devaient déchirer les
cartouches en papier avec les dents pour
mettre de la poudre dans le canon avant
d'y mettre la balle mais problème
les cartouches des nouveaux fusils sont
lubrifiés avec de la graisse animale
or les spies était majoritairement
musulman ou hindous et ne pouvait donc
pas consommer de fort ou de buzz et ça
c'est la goutte d'eau qui fait déborder
le gange en 1857 85,6 paille refuse
d'utiliser les cartouches et sont
condamnés à 10 ans de travaux forcés le
lendemain la révolte guèye le régiment
qui se mutine et la rébellion commencent
les rebelles conquiert d'allier
rapidement mais la révolte ne va pas
être uniforme dans tout le pays à cause
du manque d'unification de celui ci et
dans les régions où les rebelles sont
actifs de nombreux anglais sans défense
sont massacrées avec leurs familles
femmes et enfants compris
en angleterre la presse dépeint les
indiens comme des monstres sanguinaires
et le peuple anglais demande des
représailles équivalente la reconquête
des territoires perdus par les
britanniques ne s'embarrasseront pas de
sentiment
les insurgés sont torturées avant d'être
mises à mort et viols et massacres de
civils innocents sont commis au nom de
la vengeance des villages entiers sont
rasés sur la simple suspicion d'une
connivence avec les rebelles et délits
et rapidement reprise pour éviter le
retour d'une pareille insurrection le
pouvoir de la compagnie et transféré à
la couronne britannique en 1858
c'est le début du raj britannique un
nouveau régime colonial de indiana jones
pentecôte est un état princier dirigé
par le raja salim singh et le capitaine
blood burt en est le président
britannique est en fait l'indépendance
indienne ça va se faire par la perte de
deux compagnies commerciales c'est
vraiment une relation justement c'est du
coup c'est marrant parce que quand c'est
marrant il ya un lien en fait avec la ce
film où il ya que 2 les changes de biens
matériels c'est à dire de l'argent des
pierres précieuses visiblement un
diamant et c'est ce qui se passe en fait
dans l'histoire de l'inde a dès
l'indépendance c'est la perte de
certaines parties de société n'a et
martial donc c'est pas une dent en fait
que la révolte des cipayes de 1857 elles
soient abordés pendant le dîner parce
que c'est un événement qui a vraiment
durablement marqué les esprits et qu'à
marquer pour le coup l'inde gardienne
les protectrices de nos traditions le
maharaja de salim
dans un enfant enfant j'ai entendu
parler des horreurs de la secte des toc
je croyais qu'il ne s'agissait que d'
histoire destinée à effrayer les enfants
plus tard j'ai appris que le teg avait
vraiment existé et qu'ils avaient commis
des crimes innommables
j'ai honte de ce qui est arrivé ici et
je peux vous assurer que jamais cela ne
se reproduira tant que je règnerait je
trouve ça très pertinent petr kuzel ims
inc donc on voit à l'écran ils
prétendent avoir soutenu l'ancien
britannique paie parce qu'effectivement
la plupart des raja du rajasthan donc et
la région supposée ou se passe pas une
cote donc qu'est la région fictifs dans
le ciel et bien ils ont en effet pas
pris part à la révolte et ils ont
soutenu les britanniques
donc ça fait plutôt s'en fait
c'est la pierre qui a été volée au
village c'est une des pierres de cinq
ans car je sais pas si c'est une volonté
des scénaristes mais les terres de cinq
gars je trouve qu'elle ressemble
beaucoup au chiva ling a qui sont les
symboles du dieu shiva télé pierre way
oblongue là avec des tresses et ça et
après ils sont souvent représentés dans
un espèce de réceptacle avec un bec
verseur ils célèbrent leur culte
vous adorez venerque amis
cali c'est d'aller bien une déesse
hindoue elle réellement existé c'est la
déesse de la destruction la
représentation de cali là dans indiana
jones
elle est franchement pas nul du tout on
retrouve les éléments importants comme
par exemple la les crânes on a aussi le
pagne du bras elle tient un crâne dans
une main dans l'autre main être sain un
sabre et elle a la peau a plutôt foncée
donc ils n'ont pas fait un mauvais
travail a représenté cali alors là pour
le coup dans le film les décorateurs ils
ont été encore plus loin que les
représentations classiques
ils ont vraiment fait effrayante ça avec
un côté un peu squelettiques et tout ça
ouais mais je crois que ce film il est
enfin il est connu pour être le plus
sombre de la saga passe est très
mauvaise et très très bas et sombre et
d'ailleurs il y avait pas mal de fans
qui se sont plaints quand il est sorti
elle filme dix ans mais c'est plus le
ouais c'est plus l'indiana jones du 1 ou
lassés de l' aventure
les gamins sont sont contents quand il
voit sa mère voit la console ça un peu
gêné quoi ce qui est drôle c'est ce qui
est paradoxal en même temps c'est que
ils ont donc c'est un film qui est très
morbide mais en même temps il c'est un
des seuls films le si je dis pas de
bêtises ou un des personnages principaux
qui accompagne indiana jones dans cette
aventure c'est un enfant ouais tu vois
là avec 2000 une donc assez curieux
qu'ils aient fait ça
voix
ben ali magoudi kalima au le grand
méchant vanille mois
à limoges sortie dé quoi ah ouais
ah oui là à mes blagues tout cas
[Musique]
à
côté italien
en fait cette séquence là qu'on voit que
le sacrifice humain où on arrache un
coeur c'est pas du tout un maintien mais
on ne voit pas ça en inde
c'est vraiment ça c'est les sacrifices
humains aztèque
ça c'est très bien documenté on a des
connexes donc les codecs ce sont des
défunts des documents iconographiques
qui représente des symboles et donc on a
des temples avec plein de petits
personnages et puis en haut il ya un
sacrifice humain et donc on a on sort le
coeur et on le pose sur cet autel en
pierre donc c'est exactement ce qu'on
voit là et en plus cela le décor là avec
les pïens les crânes que convoi attaché
la sueur des sur des poteaux ça aussi
c'est aztèque
donc ça c'est complètement étranger au
sol indien
et ça c'est propre à spielberg en fait
il fait toujours ce qu'on appelle du
diffusio nisme c'est à dire estimé
qu'une pratique d'un pays c'est diffusé
partout dans le mal et qu'on retrouve
partout mais après faut se mettre aussi
bas à la place de ce réalisateur qui est
américain film et qui du coup est bien
plus imprégné par la culture mexicaine
que par la culture indienne
d'ailleurs je faire une petite
parenthèse mais là du coup le groupe
convoi est content on a déjà parlé
précédemment dans d'autres scènes
notamment pendant le banquet c les
dogues donc c'est une sorte de société
secrète de mercenaires et les tags
ils ont réellement existé c'est une
vraie compris dans indiana jones les teg
ils sont mentionnés et puis découvert
par indeed il s'agit d'une confrérie
d'assassins adorateurs de cali active en
inde au 13e jusqu'au 19e siècle et oui
alors fun fact c'est de là que vient
l'expression anglaise être intègres se
faisant passer pour donner de voyageurs
les teg obtenait la confiance des gens
les plus aisés
et lorsque l'occasion se présentait il
étrangler leurs victimes avec une corde
ou un foulard rituel ensuite il volait
et enterré leurs victimes les [ __ ]
étaient quant à eux donné aux prêtres de
l'organisation les meurtres du coup
c'était considéré comme des sacrifices
humains au nom de
la déesse kali et l'état suivait ainsi
plein de règles religieuses bien classe
présage pour désigner les victimes
rituel avant et après le meurtre langage
secret codé la totale du parfait petit
assassin mystique et donc là on pourrait
peut-être se dire que du coup le côté à
un chef de choeur s'était pas propre à
l'inde
mais c'est peut-être propres auteurs de
faire ça peut-être dans leurs cérémonies
sauf que en vérité dans indiana jones
ils ont vraiment poussé le très haut
niveau des dogues puisque ça c'est pas
ça ne fait pas du tout partie des
rituels tout le côté grandiose comme ça
avec les flammes de l'enfer et on
arrache des coeurs et tout ça c'est pas
du tout propre aux rituels tort puisque
m al'inverse les toc pour considérer que
le meurtre était réussi il devait plus
ou moins ne pas faire couler sans
d'abord un crime qui était réussi
c'était un crime où il n'avait pas de
sens qu'avec où les hoquets que le côté
trash week-end avaient tous n'ont fait
parler les aztèques ils ont vraiment
besoin du sang stern hu est ce les
traces de sang en blaguant temple au
mayor à mexico on a retrouvé les traces
de sang est ce que tu peux rappeler dans
quel contexte les cetc peuple il
pratiquait justement le sacrifice les
aztèques eux les appeaux tech etc
eh ben il ya plusieurs hypothèses donc
souvent l'hypothèse numéro un donc c'est
la guerre pour faire payer les ennemis
et donc faire une cérémonie très
symbolique et qui fait peur donc là il
sacrifiait les ennemis ou alors les
personnes de leur peuple d'accord auquel
dans les admins gars c'est pas forcément
oui c'est pas vraiment c'est pas la même
chose que la peine de mort comme on a pu
connaître en europe où on décapite forme
voilà on tue celui qui a fait une faute
dans plat notre propre société d'accord
là c'est plutôt une relation ou une
vengeance soit une vengeance voilà de la
vendetta ce genre de choses et puis à
bas la religion on sacrifie pour faire
plaisir aux yeux de dieu et c'est ce
qu'on voit dans indiana jones
officiellement qu en hindi arrive en
inde en 1935
les dogues il n'existe plus depuis un
siècle et d'ailleurs il le mentionne
dans le film il ya vraiment beaucoup de
choses à dire sur le sujet donc je vous
propose pas de le faire comme ça
maintenant à larache je vais en faire un
épisode spécial et ça arrivera bientôt
par exemple on sait toujours pas si la
confrérie a bel et bien existé ou non
mais cette confrérie d'assassins reste
très importante dans l'imaginaire
collectif
[Musique]
on posera il est une petite île et nos
sites et je pense attaquants
[Musique]
où
le sacrifice par le feu ouais c'est une
pratique qu'on retrouve dans la religion
hindouiste et ce sont notamment des
femmes qu'on appelle des satie et les
satie donc ce sont des des mortes
d'accompagnement alors c'est un peu
compliqué à expliquer c'est à dire que
leur mari est condamné au bûcher et elle
se jette dans les flammes pour les
accompagner c'est un c'est la propre
volonté ou si une cérémonie où elles
sont obligées de le faire
enfin c'est leur propre volonté c'est
dans la religion d'accord du cac c'est
un peu du lavage de cerveau mais ça
c'est fait c'est ça c'est quelque chose
qui a existé
les salariés ce sont des femmes future
veuve qui sont des modes
d'accompagnement pour les condamnés
dacca au bûcher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait indiana jones faut vraiment voir
ça comme une saga c'est à dire que les
films ont un rapport les uns avec les
autres
spielberg c'est un cinéaste qui met de
lui dans les films il a vraiment sa
personnalité son expérience avis perso
qui est dans les films et notamment sa
religion il est croyant chrétien 25 ans
et il ya vraiment une dimension à ce
qu'on appelle messianique c'est à dire
les religions comme la religion
chrétienne c'est une religion
messianique se dire qu'ils attendent le
messie ils attendent la fin des temps
l'apocalypse pour eux c'est quelque
chose qui est enviable
ils veulent la fin des temps mais là
quand on est athée on n'est pas du tout
la fin des noms on veut pas du tout
finir en amphi nation assure qu'on veut
pas du tout cramer ça souvent on oublie
mais les religions du texte en tout cas
c'est des religions qui veulent que ce
soit mais là l'apocalypse la fin des
temps que tout le monde crève pour
cueillir la répartition entre les bons
et les méchants tout là toutes les
séquences les décors sacrifices humains
c'est une métaphore de l'enfer avec
voilà les gens qui vont dans les dents
dans la loi y voilà il ya beaucoup de
souffrance et le 4 par exemple indiana
jones 4 se termine avec l'arrivée des
extraterrestres qui viennent apporter la
solution donc c'est la fin des temps
tout le monde meurt sur terre et c'est
le paradis mais le paradis sans les
humains sans vous lasser c'est vraiment
une vision très américaine très
catholique mais voilà c'est un peu c'est
une vision de l'histoire qui est
alors je disais diffusio nisme c'est à
dire bah essayé d'appliquer une vision
de l'humanité à tout là à toutes les
populations à toutes les populations
c'est pas la réalité les gens là-bas
vivent pas comme ça et est là et on l'a
montré là on l'a expliqué à plusieurs
moments quand on a vu le film ne dit pas
ça en fait c'est de la confusion s'est
pas exactement ces objets là tel endroit
voilà c'est comme toutes les fictions
qui s'inspire de l'histoire il faut
faire toujours la distinction entre la
part de réalité la part de légende et là
on peut vraiment profiter des oeuvres
artistiques
moi j'ai trouvé quand même que on peut
leur donner ça les scénaristes ils ont
fait un pas trop mauvais mena boulot à
associer justement histoire fiction et
histoire réelle
on voit ça avec par exemple le côté les
cendres de noah chi ou ça a été plutôt
bien à mener c'est cohérent on va dire
dans le storytelling de l'histoire et
d'un point de vue historique
c'est plausible même chose le fasse le
fait qu'il fasse des références à la
révolte des cipayes à la déesse kâlî qui
la représente d'une façon qui soit
également pas trop romancé
il ya des petits anachronisme il ya des
choses qui vont pas mais de façon
générale moi je trouve que il y a on
sent qu'il ya une réelle volonté de la
part du réalisateur et de la part des
scénaristes d'incorporer des éléments de
notre histoire de la vie réelle dans le
film pour le rendre un peu plus
savoureux et lui donner un peu plus de
matière de consistance ne m'a écouté
voilà moi je pense qu'on a fait le tour
j'espère que ce premier épisode du
nouveau format des boeufs une cage vous
aurez plus merci beaucoup que ledger et
à tréziers nous aider à aller voir ce
qu'ont d'ailleurs les gars j'ai besoin
de vous dans les commentaires si vous
avez des idées pour de nom pour cette
nouvelle rubrique n'hésitez pas à me
proposer petit disclaimer cependant
attention on fera pas que des
scellements là aujourd'hui on a fait un
film on pourra faire aussi parfois des
séries mais on pourra également traiter
d'autres choses de pop culture
ou alors par exemple de théories du
complot vraiment c'est du débauchage de
façon très large
donc faut pas qu'ils aient des choses
trop précises pour pas m'enfermer dans
un format et puis bah écoutez je vous
retrouve dans deux semaines pour un
prochain épisode des revues du monde
d'ici là portez vous bien un petit
rappel
allez vous
abonnés à la chaîne de la merveilleuse
clotilde dans son travail est vraiment
super a priori si vous me suivez sais
que vous aimez bien l'archéologie et
l'histoire
vous trouverez également du contenu de
super qualité sur la chaîne de clotilde
donc profité en malaisie est sûre ce
vous fait des bisous ouais salut merci
chers à lui même salut
[Musique]